is my absolute favorite news story
of I don't know the past year this is so
so funny
there's a state senator in California
Democrat by the name of Scott weiner
if you've heard that name before it is
in the context of Scott weiner pushing a
bill which then did did become law to
give more lenient punishments to
pederasts to men who sexually abuse
minors to to make it such that they're
more likely to get lenient sentences
and his name is Scott Weiner and that's
just amazing
so Scott weiner has just come out and he
he said
not even 24 hours after mag grifter
Charlie Kirk tweeted homophobic lies
about me I received this threat
repeating one of his lies and that was
the point riling people up against me
and other lgbtq people words have
consequences and Twitter is becoming a
cesspool for this crap first of all
pretty amazing that this guy is lumping
in
pedos and and pedo supporters with lgbtq
I mean is that not in itself a bit
homophobic wouldn't you say state
senator weiner uh but here's what he
says he received
after that awful Charlie Kirk told
terrible lies about him this is the
threat that he received and he includes
just a screenshot of it
it's a shame you come out and you're
okay to release all these pedophiles
you're okay with people intentionally
giving other people AIDS and your office
can't even pick up the phone to answer
about these questions you're sick man I
don't even call you you shouldn't even
be a man you're sick individual I don't
care about what you do off hours but
once when you try to force it upon
California it's like myself and others
you'll have something coming to you
people like you won't be able to walk
down the streets when light comes to the
darkness that you're effing providing
you piece of s-h-i-t
wow man that's a threat that is that's a
real threat that's not good to threaten
people
except there was something a little bit
weird about this screenshot of the
message that Scott weiner allegedly
received
it has a cursor right at the end of it
now
the cursor is the thing that you see
when you type something on the computer
you know it's just that blinking line
when you are writing a Word document or
a note
so I've just got a little bit of a pro
tip for Scott weiner
when when you are fabricating a threat
against yourself
it is really smart to remove your cursor
from the screenshot before you post it
to Twitter I'm amazed that at the end of
this threat
the the uh would be assailant didn't say
this is Maga country
give me your Subway sandwich Senator
weiner Senator weiner have you ever been
on the show Empire
it it's so the guy just totally got
exposed
and now we cover this on the show a lot
when these
hate crime threat homophobic racist
sexist when these when these things make
it into the news
a lot of the time maybe most of the time
they turn out to be hoaxes they turn out
to be Jesse Smollett situations and that
would seem to be what's going on here so
I wasn't the only guy to notice this a
number of other people did too and then
sometime later
Scott weiner had to answer this and so
he said
and for all the Maga conspiracy
theorists out there the threat was a
voicemail
and this is a transcription but have fun
spinning around with your conspiracies
anything has a little eye rolling emoji
oh hold on see
you you told us initially that you got
this this threat
and then he posted the screenshot
which had the cursor I forgot to mention
the threat also had a little uh spell
check lines underneath it because the
grammar was off so you want to turn that
off too when you when you fabricate your
own threads but now he's saying no no it
actually wasn't an email or a text or
anything it was a voicemail that I I
transcribed but if it was a voicemail
why wouldn't why wouldn't you just post
the audio
you could post that to Twitter that'd be
very easy in fact it would it would be
much more engaging if there were a
little sort of video screen with the
with the audio playing and you could you
could hear this guy and probably make it
easier to identify the man who's making
this threat this awful terrible Maga
right-wing conservative who
almost certainly does not exist right
I think probably if if he did post the
audio which does not exist of this which
almost certainly doesn't exist it would
probably sound like that Nigerian guy
who was who is uh paid to attack Jesse
Smollett in Chicago
doesn't hold up does not hold up I think
Senator Scott weiner
should take the L
anybody
any reasonable person would have to say
this is most likely
almost certainly a
hoax a threat perpetrated fabricated by
Scott weiner upon himself and you should
just take the L and move on bro just
take the L move on this this response
that he gave later after we noticed his
cursor in the spell check lines is
almost as bad as my Twitter was hacked
no one ever symbolitician actually wow
oh my gosh when
when Anthony Weiner got caught sending
weird sexual photos of himself to people
on Twitter and he meant to privately
message them but he publicly messaged
them what was his excuses excuses well
my Twitter got hacked this is almost as
bad as an excuse as my Twitter got
hacked I don't don't believe it buddy
sorry
no we're we're going to continue to
criticize you and other politicians who
openly Advocate being lenient to
pederasts pedophiles broadly
sorry buddy sorry I I hope you held on
to your Subway sandwich
[Music]
[Music]